people of the internet retroback and  tour here when playstation announced the  hogwarts legacy state of play they  actually revealed a very short clip  containing this moment from the game now  everybody is talking about this statue  right here i want to know who you think  it is i've heard salazar slytherin i've  heard maybe merlin i've heard herpo the  foul i could see all of those as being  possible candidates or maybe it's  someone completely new this also looks  like a very similar room to the one that  we see in the original trailer safe to  say i think we're going to be seeing  more of this on thursday with the state  of play i will be live streaming you can  catch me over on twitch.tv  retrorecontour hope to see you guys  there